The annual flu shot has been
a consistent staple
in many of our lives since the 1940s.
And for the past 80 years, the way
we research and make it
has remained mostly unchanged.
Which is not really a problem.
The flu shot is estimated to save
thousands of lives every year
and prevent millions of cases
in the United States alone.
In other words, it’s a safe and effective
way to stop the seasonal flu strain.
But what if something
different emerged?
The last four pandemics before Covid-19
were brought on by an influenza virus,
not a coronavirus.
And virologists agree that when it
comes to the next flu pandemic,
it’s not if, but when.
But the Covid-19 pandemic has brought us
new advances in vaccine technology.
And now we're closer than ever before
to something new.
Something like a flu shot that protects us
year after year, regardless of the strain.
Something like a universal flu vaccine.
There are a lot of different types of influenza
and researchers identify each one by looking at
two proteins on the surface of the virus:
hemagglutinin and neuraminidase.
Each one has various subtypes, which can create
a ton of different combinations.
And that’s just influenza A viruses.
There’s also influenza B to worry about.
A truly universal vaccine would have
to cover all of these
plus anything that could potentially emerge.
SCHULTZ-CHERRY: So what makes influenza
unique is its ability to change rapidly.
That's why we have to update
our vaccines every year,
because as it goes through people,
it changes.
The trouble is, making the vaccine takes
a lot of time every year,
so in order to have a vaccine ready
for flu season
researchers have to rely on a bit of guesswork.
FULLER: We have to almost predict
“What is next year's flu virus
going to look like?”
Since the flu is a seasonal virus that
typically appears in the colder months
scientists predict the most common strains
by looking at outbreaks
in other areas of the world.
SCHULTZ-CHERRY: They'll make the decision
for February
for that next September's vaccine
in the northern hemisphere.
Researchers typically choose the top 4
most common strains in one hemisphere
to make the flu vaccine
for the other hemisphere.
But since the virus is constantly changing,
the predictions in February aren’t always
100% accurate by September.
FULLER: The efficacy of the flu vaccine can vary
from as little as 30%, up to 70%
from any one given year
simply because those predictions
are not always perfect.
They're pretty good,
but they're not perfect.
One solution would be to just make the vaccine
closer to flu season.
But the way we currently make the flu vaccine
makes that impossible.
SCHULTZ-CHERRY: Right now, our current practice takes
6 to 8 months to make the vaccine.
Scientists have used fertilized chicken eggs
to grow viruses for vaccines since the 40’s.
In fact, we use so many eggs
to make flu vaccines annually
that the US government actually has top secret
chicken farms for this specific purpose.
But that’s a story for another time.
The point is, when a virus is prone
to changing rapidly,
6 to 8 months is a ton of wasted time.
Newer vaccine technology like mRNA
could dramatically shrink this timeline
because it doesn’t require growing
large quantities of viruses.
As in, we could do away with
the chickens and the eggs.
We’d likely be able to make a much more
effective flu vaccine
because we’d be developing shots
closer to the time
we actually discover the new strain.
This is one way to potentially improve the
flu shot, but only up to a point.
Because making a vaccine faster
doesn’t make it universal.
To do that, we have to teach our immune system
to target a different part of the virus entirely.
Influenza changes fast,
but not the entire virus.
Just a few pieces - specifically the top part
of that one protein
called hemagglutinin, which is
kind of shaped like a tulip.
SCHULTZ-CHERRY: The head of the tulip,
that's where we currently
make antibodies to.
And that's the area that changes
super fast,
so it’ll go from a red to a white
to a yellow.
In simplest terms, our annual flu shot
teaches our body
to recognize the top of that protein:
the "tulip head."
Which is why one vaccine that teaches our
immune system to fight off a yellow tulip
isn’t good for the next year
when a red tulip shows up.
For a universal vaccine to work
it needs to teach our immune system
to recognize and fight off
a part of the virus that doesn’t change
as much.
Which means instead of focusing on the head
that changes year after year,
from virus to virus,
many researchers have turned
their attention to the stem.
FULLER: The hemagglutinin stem has been a target
for universal flu vaccines
for quite some time.
KRAMMER: The problem with our immune system,
is that it doesn't like to actually target the stalk.
So you basically have to find a way
to convince the immune system
that it finds the stalk attractive.
There are a few ways to do that.
Some researchers have tried
removing the head all together.
Others have found promise in swapping out
the head multiple times
so your immune system only recognizes
the stem as a threat,
and builds a stronger immune response to that.
Now, there are also other parts of the virus
that don’t change as much
that researchers are looking at,
which will likely be vital
for an effective universal flu vaccine as well.
FULLER: There's always the possibility
that down the line
once you generate, say,
a universal flu vaccine
focused on the hemagglutinin stem,
that eventually the virus
will figure out a way to mutate away
from that as well.
An ideal universal influenza vaccine
will not include just one conserved bit
from the virus,
but multiple conserved portions from the virus.
And if we could do that,
it doesn’t really matter how fast
we make the vaccine.
Because it would work year after year,
on multiple different strains of the flu.
There’s still a bit of research
left to do:
trials, funding, and more.
But we’re closer than you might think.
FULLER: There are already universal
flu vaccines in clinical trials.
So, we're looking at, you know, years,
a few years down the line.
KRAMMER: I think 5 to 10 years
is a timeframe that sounds
at least to me, reasonable.
For most people, the implications
of a universal flu shot
are bigger than just not having to get
a vaccine every year.
It would also make the flu vaccine
more broadly available.
KRAMMER: The flu vaccines are
vaccines for rich countries, right?
Low and middle income countries,
specifically low income countries
don't have the infrastructure and the capacity
to actually use them.
A universal flu shot that lasts
for several years
could be implemented in
childhood vaccination programs globally,
providing better protection for everyone from
current and future outbreaks.
KRAMMER: We need to kind of put the resources
into it because otherwise
we won't be prepared for the next
flu pandemic either.
FULLER: So, we can do better,
especially with the new technologies
like mRNA vaccines that have emerged.
There is a real opportunity to do
much, much better
in terms of protecting against flu each year.